welcome back to New rockstars I'm
Jessica Clemens here to talk to you
about she-hole Daredevil and what to
expect since we've last seen him our
baby boy grew up and donned a new suit
looking fresh to death like in the
comics for the She-Hulk series and I'm a
proud mama
[Music]
this is my boy but there's more to
growth than just outgrowing your clothes
it's also in relationships and trust and
who's better at that than She-Hulk and
Daredevil here I'll set up a couple
different ways this could possibly go
and how every plot is still super fun
and very badass we're all stoked and
yoked about Daredevil fully entering MCU
since feige swiped them up from Netflix
we've got two lawyers here so we know
they're gonna go to court soon or at
least battle laws can you tell I don't
know how lawyers work I went to school
for communications I don't know laws I
also break a lot of them indirectly
right to jail right away last we saw him
as in Spider-Man no way home as Peter
Parker's lawyer for adjacent characters
like Kingpin we saw him last in Hawkeye
both characters have been firmly placed
in the MCU and play into my theory so we
can Bank on their cameos coming into
play as well but more specifically for
Daredevil Jessica gal head writer and
creator for She-Hulk mentioned in an
interview with glider we just kept
writing them in we kept rolling with the
story just thinking like okay at any
moment they're gonna tell us that we
can't use them I think that quote gave
away a lot to what we can see in their
dynamic in the show The Writers might
have been prepared to lose him at any
moment I'm sure Marvel would make a
cameo like Matt Murdock strong and
clearly help Brown inch to something
else so whether it's his new show born
again or echo or even Thunderbolts we
need to know how this Locomotion starts
in She-Hulk we last Saw Matt fully in
season three of Daredevil let's remember
shall we Matt is mourning the loss of
Elektra after the Defenders while foggy
and Karen mourn his death you get a lot
of Senseless Murder By Dex find Matt's
mom bring Vanessa back in the end we get
an epic showdown between dexmack and
Wilson fist Dex spine gets crumbled fist
goes to prison foggy Karen and Matt
reunite happily everything's blue skies
and sunshine and then we see Dex being
worked on by Kenji oyama and the rest is
history literally we just don't get a
season four and I cry still about it now
seeing as we're getting Daredevil's
Revival Daredevil born again we consume
they'll probably take a lot of stuff
from season three because season three
and Frank Miller's 1986 run of Daredevil
Born Again share a lot of distressing
similarities born again is heavy it's
written by Frank Miller of course it's
heavy this leads me to idea number one
how can we go from season three
Daredevil to She-Hulk to Daredevil born
again yes there will probably be other
smaller cameos but seeing as Matt
Murdock was representing Peter Parker
and his mission is to represent the
underreated Senate he's still probably
trying to reach out and represent
wrongfully convicted superheroes or
prosecute really bad unconvicted felons
I know I'll get to his prosecution stuff
later this could be our connection to
Kingpin we know he was up to no good
before and during Hawkeye and we still
don't know what he was doing during the
blip this could be the time he reaches
out to Jennifer Walters superhero lawyer
extraordinaire to help him in his case
against Fisk or maybe her firm is
defending him Jen is a phenomenal lawyer
and even in the comics people wanted her
so bad because she'd bring bigger
clients though foggy could never bring
an end to fist's Reign maybe help from
shio could what inevitably would
probably happen is Kingpin gets off
Jennifer would realize the system is
flawed start working for her own firm
and then Born Again Kingpin raises hell
probably killing foggy and Karen you
know doing evil ass guy [ __ ] remember
when villains just wanted to blow up the
moon now they're killing your best
friends how you like that you ask for it
you get it this now brings us to idea
number two and how she hopes Daredevil
will set up his cameo in the Echo series
we know both Charlie Cox and Vincent
nofrio will carry on Echo so if what I
argued earlier is true getting close to
Kingpin and chi-hulk would be a long
game but worth it in the end to see him
Maya Lopez and Daredevil and echo in the
comics smile Lopez first appeared in
Daredevil Issue Number Nine where they
wanted to make a character who had been
through the same experiences as
Daredevil but where he's blind she's
deaf she also learns to fight like
Daredevil in the comics watching him in
Bullseye fight so we could get some
hints of him looking for a sparring
partner like Titania is dashihole now on
to idea number three three
oh okay okay number three we're setting
up the Thunderbolts baby what went down
between Abomination and Hulk in 2008's
Incredible Hulk went down in history as
The Duel of Harlem for the Harlem Terror
in Daredevil season 1. this might have
looked great to Valentina Allegra de
Fontaine all caller just vow for Now
setting up the Thunderbolts team but to
people like Daredevil that was a
massacre the dash will confirmed for me
because I'm not from New York that
Harlem and Hell's Kitchen are both in
Manhattan so he definitely Daredevil
probably lost a lot of people in that
maybe he shares his disinterest as she
hoped to defending a guy like
Abomination maybe he's just gonna be the
prosecutor regardless this is perfect
timing to use Daredevil as the voice of
reason or when Prosecuting him and Val
shows up just to pick up the pieces or
maybe Jen simply unknowingly works for
the same organization that works for Val
they could be working together and Jen
every time she gets these super villains
off they go directly into the hands of
Al
I know what you're thinking Jessica he
normally defends he's never prosecutor
stupid that brings me to idea number
four we know from the comics Matt and
Jennifer even has friends that fought
alongside one another but we never
really see them in court facing off
against each other that is until
She-Hulk issue number four shioka's
friends with Matt so much so she goes in
for advice they later go head to head
gen defending and map Prosecuting Steve
Rogers this is one of my favorite runs
and I would love to see something like
this because Steve hired them both
because Matt wouldn't let up so easily
and as for She-Hulk he says and I quote
I didn't want to lose you now oh God I
just love it even if hired by the
government we can still see Daredevil
potentially prosecute people and also
other than smart Hulk she can relate to
Matt being a vigilante by night and a
lawyer by day this has potential to be
their friendship origin story and that's
really all I want because Daredevil
needs a friend like She-Hulk and she
hooked me as a friend like Daredevil
that's just a little bit a little bit of
tea theorization for you I don't know if
that's a word I've theorized there you
go let me know yours in the comments
below follow me on Instagram and Twitter
at Lulu underscore Clemons follow new
rock star subscribing hit that
notification Bell follow us on Discord
as long as you're 18 plus thanks for
watching chain now just go somewhere go
go get out of here read some comics
[Music]